what's up everybody
24 it's coming back where as I like to
call it the Jack Bauer Power Hour 24 has
been gone for long years so we're about
to give you everything you need to feel
like you're up to speed
124 returns this is the idiots guide to
24 cue that awesome sound by the way
guys this is just a summary and overview
if we hit every plot point and
double-cross and dead end we would be
here for 24 hours just like Jack Bauer
the first season of 24 revolves around
the assassination attempt on senator and
Democratic presidential candidate David
Palmer senator
oh I hope it was insured with Allstate
there are also multiple kidnappings of
Jack Bauer's wife and daughter this show
makes taken and taken to look like a
lovely picnic in the park here's who we
meet in season one Jack's wife Terry her
time on the show is short and sweet she
gets killed
causing Jack to cry powerful man tears
him Bauer
troubled daughter hot kidnap bait Tony
he's a sad sack works a counterterrorism
unit he's kind of like the ER of 24 and
then there's Nina Jack's former lover
confidant and mother-effing traitor
she's the one that killed Jack's wife in
the last episode of the season the first
of innumerable CTU moles hey government
disband CTU it is a snake pit season two
not a great day for Jack and not the
great season Jack has to stop terrorists
from releasing a nuke in the middle of
Los Angeles but our boy Jack is bearded
grizzled as hell and not gonna let that
happen throughout the season Jack helps
blow up CTU to maintain his cover gets
tortured to death dies comes back to
life kills a bunch of dudes while naked
saves the day and Jack doesn't smile
once during that entire damn season oh
and even though this wasn't a great
season
it may be had the coolest 24 moment ever
I'm gonna need a hacksaw and in a
ridiculous turn of events Jack Bauer's
daughter Kim gets caught in a cougar
trap remember when I was talking about
the coolest moment in 24 history this
was the lamest season 3 mucho loco SH
happens Jack is undercover with a
Mexican drug cartel and he's addicted to
heroin this season Jack Bauer was
breaking bad before Breaking Bad was
Breaking Bad season 3 is also notable
for when Jack finally murders Nina you
don't have any
but on a lovely lighter note we meet
Chloe Jack's quirky brilliant possibly
autistic assistant Anna Chloe just do it
now Chloe she's the best season four
jack is fired from CTU for his heroin
addiction what a strict workplace no
heroin he starts working for the
Secretary of Defense James Heller and
Jack's actually kind of happy but don't
worry goes down the main bad guy is
Habib Marwan this guy's up to all kinds
of stuff he kidnapped secretary Heller
and his daughter Audrey Jack's
lady things are looking rough until Jack
busts in and mows down like 15 people in
six minutes it's incredible then Habib
marwan's men steal a stealth fighter and
shoot down Air Force One with the
president down for the count we meet VP
Charles Logan who basically takes over
Logan is the most weaselly piece of
trash in the 24 universe Jack breaks
into the Chinese consulate it's caught
and fakes his own death with the help of
Chloe and Tony hey what are friends for
if not to hope you faked your own death
day five it starts with a bang in the
first 10 minutes of the season
president Palmer dies Michelle Dressler
dies and Tony Almeida died this brings
Jack Bauer out of hiding to start saving
the day again this just in Charles Logan
is still a piece of garbage he was
behind a plot for the Russians to steal
nerve gas and attack the CTU Jack knows
what's up and he's gonna get a
confession at Charles Logan
mr. Logan I'm not gonna torture you but
you are gonna tell me what I want to
know so help me God
now helium and today Jack saved the
world again got back with Audrey was
gonna reconcile with Kim but then gets
snatched up and put on a slow boat to
chuck
damn it season six day six these
summaries are gonna get a lot shorter
now because we can all agree that this
shows best days are behind it at this
point
Jack kills like the only guy loyal to
him Curtis and then they blow up
Valencia California with a nuke and then
it turns out that the bad guys were
Jack's dad and brother here's one
important thing audrey has been
kidnapped
jackets are fact because that's how Jack
does it but her dad is all like stay
away from my daughter cuz anyone who
gets close to you dies sooner or later
you're gonna get back in the game and my
daughter's gonna pay the price
like your wife did dick season ends with
Jack staring wistfully at the ocean
wondering what happened to 24 this show
is still going season 7 another storm of
a day the Senate is trying to send Jack
Bauer to prison for torture arrest Jack
Bauer for torture
that's like arresting Beyonce for
singing oh look at this Tony back from
the dead trying to avenge his dead wife
or something and then jack gets exposed
to biological weapons and he's got hours
to live
but his daughter offers him some of her
superhot stem cells but he doesn't want
him because he's a Republican to the end
it's my choice now
I mean in my mind but he takes the stem
cells anyway in Jack's fine season a day
the last season you know the thing with
last season's they're either great when
we go out on top or kind of forgettable
guess which category this falls into
season eight takes place in New York
City I call it Jack Takes Manhattan
just like the Muppets you guys so
there's terrorists there's double
crosses there's dirty bombs there's
nuclear rods there's Freddie Prinze jr.
all you really need to know is Jack
leaves on the run from the government
leave the country while you still have a
chance the Russians will be coming after
you
that's all away Jack gives a heartfelt
goodbye to Chloe I never thought it was
gonna be you it was gonna cover my back
all those years thank you
and then he's a ghost until now are you
looking forward to 24 what do you thinks
gonna happen what did we leave out that
you're pissed about let us know in the
comments section below the coolest
answer you're going to get a screen
junkies t-shirt I want to thank you for
watching this idiots guide I'm the idiot
Hal Rudnick hit me up on Twitter bye-bye
donar the plan of the ass this is my
number one film of the whole song
Loretta down I am beyond sight
Yves [ __ ] horses I will the Apes on
horses beat the Transformers on Dinobot